mr beast literally puts his life on the
line with so many of his challenges and
we're gonna talk about that as well as
hashtag team c's
a marathon is 26 miles and today with no
prior training we're going to attempt it
with the world's largest pair of shoes
i'm nervous already because two problems
arise here one running a marathon with
no prior training incredibly bad for
your body now i'm not just talking about
your joints your muscles your tendons
i'm talking about your kidneys when you
have a rapid breakdown of muscle tissue
which happens during a marathon because
of the tremendous stress your body's
under you actually break down that
muscle tissue releasing myoglobin which
is actually toxic to your kidneys no
joke i've seen people who were untrained
run a marathon and then pee blood after
wow
and then running in the shoes obviously
that's ridiculous my man everything's
gonna hurt anything you put into your
shoe the amount of foam there the
flexibility of your soul that will
affect your ankle then your knee then
your hip then your low back each of
these shoes weighs five pounds that's 10
pounds in total you know what's gonna
probably be sorest on him knees for one
by far also on his anterior tibialis
muscle because that's the muscle that
has to bring the shoe up in order for
you to take a step without tripping and
it's gonna be even worse with this giant
shoe the shoe was constantly scraping
the side of my feet and it was getting
extremely painful so we had to do some
modifications so they're wearing a shoe
over a shoe do you see how important
proper footwear is the human body works
through a biomechanical motion that has
evolved over millions of years and it's
all very well thought out it's a
beautiful process actually your weight
distribution how your foot strikes the
floor how the muscles bear the weight of
that impact and how your arch is
supposed to take in some of that force
you negate all of that by strapping this
giant shoe to the bottom of your foot
and this is chewing chestnut oh joey
joey chestnut crushes it at the hot dog
eating contest
what the [ __ ] is he doing this is as
fast as i can eat competitive food
eaters scare the life out of me because
i have no idea how they consume an
absurd number of calories and don't a
put on weight b don't rupture their
stomach it's just like a magnificent
feed it's almost like magic think how
much salt is in there how much sodium is
in there that's a huge load on your
kidneys what do their bodies go through
there's no way i can do this now he does
it so fast too
one final bite
oh my god before we started we weighed
him and he weighed 229. let's go see
what he weighs now that was one of the
hardest challenges of my life step on
the scale let's see how much weight you
gave no way he weighs 250 well he drank
a lot of water too god i can't imagine
going to the bathroom after that must be
like not gonna lie though i would
probably fare pretty well at this
we will be spending 24 hours in this
insane asylum first of all we don't call
them insane asylums we don't have insane
asylums like this we actually also moved
away from using restraints in patients
we prefer using someone to watch over
them perhaps medication options to help
calm them down but this is just like
really barbaric this is like what used
to happen 200 years ago
so we were letting chandler poop and
i tore my labrum and my shoulder like
popped out of socket and it really hurt
how did he tear his labrum
the fact that his shoulder dislocated is
a really big problem the most common
form of uh shoulder dislocations are
anterior shoulder dislocations you need
to put them back because otherwise it's
really a lot of pain
the doctors have said that they're
pretty sure that i've blown either one
or both of my eardrums
because my eardrums are full of pus and
stuff like that and i have an infection
this is a difficult explanation here he
may or may not have blown an eardrum
which you could see if you just do an
otoscope exam there if that's the case
due to an infection that would be
treatable with antibiotics so i'm not
sure if there's like a eustachian tube
dysfunction that's also simultaneously
going on which is the tube that connects
your sinuses to your ears which can make
like popping sensations pressure
differentials become quite painful the
idea that he has just like nighttime ear
pain randomly warrants further
investigation or at least a better
explanation for me in this video we will
be eating a 70 000 pizza that's an
expensive pizza we have an ounce of gold
that's covering the crust 10 year old
parmesan bechamel japanese beef has been
marinated overnight in a ten thousand
dollar bottle this is so ridiculous
this is only in america gold is is an
inert substance so it's gonna just like
go through your digestive system and
you're gonna poop it out not something i
recommend eating regularly don't eat
metal oh my god i feel like that's a
pretty standard piece of medical advice
oh my god straight up i really really
like it no way so we're going to act
like my channel was hacked and the only
way for me to get my channel back is to
raise a million dollars through selling
body parts and organs you see your body
parts are actually worth a lot they are
but they're not legal to sell especially
here in the united states there is
actually one country where you can sell
your organs and it is legal it's one
country in the whole world iran kidneys
are twenty two hundred thousand whoa i
can get two hundred grand for a kidney
you can live with one kid but you have
to be very careful in that instance
cause you gotta take care of your soul
kidney you gotta watch out for
medications that you can take that can
negatively impact your kidneys advil
motrin aleve things that you won't even
realize could pose a serious serious
risk to your kidneys skeletons three to
five grand who's selling skeletons he's
definitely reading like a board game
nothing like this has nothing to do with
reality livers okay so according to this
article obviously you can't live without
you can't live without your liver but if
your liver is damaged it does regenerate
and if you cut pieces off we actually
see it regenerate so technically if i
donate half my liver the other half will
grow back therefore i'm definitely
selling half my liver so we're gonna add
that to the list he has a microsoft word
file open selling his organs according
to this article people can survive even
if an entire lung is removed i actually
had a friend growing up his dad was
unfortunately attacked in new york city
as a taxi cab driver and he was left
with only one lung you can live with one
load a gram of bone marrow is worth 23
000
on the black market you could actually
do bone marrow donations even now for
people who are battling cancer for
example my mom needed bone marrow
donations from individuals so don't
expect to get 23 g's though i'm going to
attempt to sit under water for 24 hours
straight this this is this one's painful
to watch because a lot happens here but
i have this tube right here and this
tube is going to be constantly feeding
me oxygen there's just so many variables
and stresses that his body's gonna have
to face like his skin's gonna prove he's
not moving well cramps of his muscles
he's also gonna have obviously sleep
deprivation because he's going to be up
for 24 hours there's just a lot of
things that can go wrong and very easy
for him to feel unwell and need to leave
the challenge and my hands are so soggy
also i think this is a chlorinated pool
extended exposure to chlorine actually
can cause skier skin irritation damage
rashes when you see individuals spend a
ton of time uh submerged in water their
skin actually starts breaking down and
then they start getting fungal and
bacterial infections
the skin prune thing is probably the
most interesting part of this video
because a lot of people assume that skin
pruning has something to do with
electrolytes or things like that that's
what i even used to think this is an
autonomic nervous system response that
helps us better navigate wet surfaces
and wet objects and the way we actually
found this out is because we found those
who had nerve damage to those areas
weren't pruning in water so it's crazy
that our bodies have evolved in order to
help us survive when we get wet by
giving us extra traction as if we had
tires on our feet how cool is that
i need some air
i wish he had an oxygen sensor in there
to know how much oxygen he's getting
there may have been periods of time
where there was a lot of co2 in there
not enough oxygen he could have easily
started developing hypoxia from lack of
oxygen in
there actually starting to get a little
freezing in here the water being not
body temperature even if it's 70 degrees
you know it may feel okay it could
actually cause you to develop
hypothermia in like a few hours because
the water is so cold and your body's not
acclimated to this because your natural
body temperature is around 98 degrees
you can start developing hypothermia
because you aren't able to keep your
body temperature up but i randomly
started feeling extremely sick while
sitting under water and i had to come
out like i just had this strong urge to
throw up i think it's because the water
was constantly moving i was just getting
really seasick under there seasick
hypothermic pruning hypoxic not enough
oxygen there's just so many variables in
here that make him feel unwell it's not
surprising that he had to come out i'm
gonna spend the next 50 hours buried
alive in this coffin probably the
dumbest thing i've ever done this one
legit scares me because he's gonna be
trapped in there for a while
oh stop oh my god imagine he fell
through and he just fell right onto his
body broke a rib oh i tried to turn
around it was like very narrow on the
other end i love that he has food and
hydration that's all important i really
hope he stays mobile in this thing by
not moving for long periods of time
blood actually stagnates in your body
especially in the lower extremities you
can actually have clots form that then
can get loose shot up into your lungs
and cause a pulmonary embolism you've
officially made it underground 24 hours
yeah really so how do you feel after
being in underground for 24 hours my
back hurts starting to feel
claustrophobic claustrophobia is a legit
phobia a lot of people suffer with this
it's one of the top phobias in the
united states when you're not moving
you're putting pressure on certain areas
you can actually develop bed sores for
patients who are paralyzed we have to
constantly reposition them otherwise we
have decreased circulation of skin to
that area it starts getting red at first
and then it actually opens up as a sore
it can turn black and like a full hole
in the body i have to poop really bad
but i've decided just to hold it not
pooping for 48 hours is not the end of
the world you know patients can go a
week without pooping and obviously
that's like a constipation diagnosis but
it's not something that is lethal or
deadly
this is probably the most dangerous part
of this video because if any of that
fireworks smoke actually got into his
coffin he can actually get really sick
from carbon monoxide poisoning very fast
and they might just think he fell asleep
but he's actually developed carbon
monoxide poisoning that's one of the
symptoms do not allow smoke to occur in
an enclosed space that is literally
deadly
the reason i actually reacted to all
these mr beast videos is because i've
teamed up with him and creators from all
around the world to promote team seas
and international efforts to raise 30
million dollars to remove 30 million
pieces of trash from our oceans rivers
and waterways all you have to do is head
over to teamses.org to learn more and
donate as little as a dollar to remove
one piece of trash or simply share this
video with the hashtag teamc's to help
make sure that our oceans are happy and
healthy if you want to watch me kick
some butt and box literally box because
i'm a doctor boxer now click here to
check that out and as always stay happy
and healthy
[Music]